se transforme en une maladie soignable, traitable.
Vous avez une pneumonie,
prenez de la pénicilline,
vous tuez le microbe
et vous soignez la maladie.
Cette idée était si séduisante,
cette image du verrou et de la clé, si puissante,
l'idée de tuer quelque chose,
qu'elle a vraiment renversé la biologie.
Ce fut une transformation incomparable.
Et nous avons en fait passé le siècle suivant
à essayer de reproduire ce modèle encore et encore
sur des maladies non-infectieuses
sur des maladies chroniques comme le diabète, l'hypertension, la cardiopathie.
Et ça a marché, mais seulement partiellement.
Laissez-moi vous montrer.
Vous savez, si vous prenez l'univers entier
de toutes les réactions chimiques se produisant dans le corps humain,
chaque réaction chimique dont notre corps est capable,
la plupart des gens estiment ce chiffre à environ un million.
Disons donc un million.
Et maintenant vous vous demandez
quel nombre ou fraction de réactions
peuvent en faite être visées
par toute la pharmacopée, par toute la chimie médicinale ?
Ce nombre est 250.
Le reste est un flou chimique.
En d'autres mots, 0,025 % de toutes les réactions chimiques dans votre corps
peuvent réellement être l'objet de ce mécanisme de clé et de serrure.
Vous savez, si on considère la physiologie humaine
comme un vaste réseau téléphonique global
avec des nœuds en interaction et des pièces en interaction,
alors toute notre chimie médicinale
fonctionne dans un seul petit coin
sur la bordure, la bordure extérieure de ce réseau.
Comme si toute notre chimie pharmaceutique
était un opérateur à Wichita, dans le Kansas
qui bricolerait environ 10 ou 15 lignes téléphoniques.
Alors, que faire de cette idée ?
Et si on réorganisait cette approche ?
En fait, il se trouve que la nature
nous fait entrevoir une façon de penser la maladie
radicalement différente
du schéma : maladie, médicament, cible.
En fait, le monde naturel est hiérarchiquement organisé vers le haut,
pas vers le bas, mais vers le haut,
et cela commence avec la cellule, une unité auto-régulatrice, semi-autonome.
Ces unités auto-régulatrices et semi-autonomes
engendrent des unités auto-régulatrices et semi-autonomes, les organes,
et ces organes forment ensemble des choses : les humains,
et ces organismes vivent enfin dans des environnements,
qui sont en partie auto-régulés, en partie semi-autonomes.
Ce qui est sympa dans ce schéma, ce schéma hiérarchique
qui se construit vers le haut plutôt que vers le bas,
c'est qu'il nous permet aussi de penser à la maladie
d'une façon assez différente.
Prenez une maladie comme le cancer.
Depuis les années 50,
nous avons essayé plutôt désespérément
d'appliquer ce modèle de clé et de serrure au cancer.
Nous avons essayé de tuer les cellules
à l'aide d'une variété de chimiothérapies ou de thérapies ciblées,
et, beaucoup d'entre nous le savent, ça a marché.
Ça a marché pour des maladies telles que la leucémie,
ça a marché pour certains types de cancer du sein,
mais un jour ou l'autre, on arrive au bout de cette approche.
Et c'est seulement dans les dix dernières années
qu'on a envisagé d'utiliser le système immunitaire,
en se rappelant que la cellule cancéreuse n'évolue pas dans le vide,
mais bien dans un organisme humain.
Et pourrait-on utiliser les capacités organiques,
le système immunitaire humain, contre le cancer ?
En fait, c'est la base de certains des plus spectaculaires traitements du cancer.
Et enfin, il y a le plan de l'environnement, non ?
Vous savez, personne ne fait le lien entre cancer et environnement.
Mais laissez-moi vous donner un exemple
d'environnement profondément cancérigène.
Ça s'appelle une prison.
Prenez la solitude, prenez la dépression, prenez le confinement,
et ajoutez à cela,
roulé dans une petite feuille de papier blanc,
un des plus puissants neurostimulants que l'on connaisse, appelé la nicotine,
et ajoutez à cela une des substances les plus addictives que l'on connaisse,
et vous avez un environnement pro-cancérigène.
Mais il y a aussi des environnements anti-cancérigènes.
Certains tentent de créer des milieux,
de modifier le milieu hormonal pour le cancer du sein, par exemple.
On tente de modifier le milieu métabolique pour d'autres formes de cancers.
Ou prenez une autre maladie, comme la dépression.
Encore une fois, en agissant vers le haut,
depuis les années 60 et 70, nous avons essayé, à nouveau, désespérément,
de désactiver les molécules qui opèrent entre les cellules nerveuses --
la sérotonine, la dopamine --
et tenté de soigner la dépression ainsi,
et ça a marché, mais après ça la limite était atteinte.
Et aujourd'hui, on sait que ce qu'il faut sans doute faire,
c'est changer la physiologie de l'organe, du cerveau
le recâbler, le remodeler,
et que, bien sûr, nombre d'études ont montré
que la psychothérapie a exactement cet effet,
et nombre d'études ont montré que combiner cette thérapie
avec des médicaments, des pilules,
est beaucoup plus efficace que l'un des deux seul.
Peut-on imaginer un milieu plus immersif qui changerait la dépression ?
Peut-on isoler les signaux qui provoquent la dépression ?
À nouveau, déplaçons-nous vers le haut de l'organisation hiérarchique.
Ce qui est peut-être vraiment en jeu ici
ce n'est pas la médecine elle-même, mais une métaphore.
Plutôt que de tuer quelque chose,
dans le cas des grandes maladies dégénératives chroniques --
insuffisance rénale, diabète, hypertension, arthrose --
ce qu'on doit peut-être faire,
c'est remplacer « tuer » par « cultiver ».
Et c'est peut-être le point-clé
qui recadrera notre façon de penser la médecine.
Et cette idée de changer,
de créer une sorte de changement de perception,
s'est imposée à moi de façon très personnelle il y a environ 10 ans.
Il y a 10 ans -- j'ai fait de la course presque toute ma vie --
Je suis allé courir, un samedi matin,
je suis rentré, et au réveil, je ne pouvais plus bouger.
Mon genou droit avait enflé,
et on entendait le craquement menaçant de l'os contre l'os.
Et un des avantages d'être médecin, c'est qu'on peut se prescrire des IRM.
Et j'ai fait une IRM la semaine d’après, et ça ressemblait à ça.
En résumé, le ménisque de cartilage entre les os
était complètement déchiré, et l'os lui-même était brisé.
Mais si je vous inspire de la pitié,
laissez-moi vous dire quelque chose.
Si je faisais passer une IRM à chaque personne de ce public,
60% d'entre vous montreraient des signes
de dégénérescence osseuse et cartilagineuse, comme ici.
85% de toutes les femmes de 70 ans
montreraient des signes parfois sévères de dégénérescence cartilagineuse.
50 à 60% des hommes de ce public montreraient aussi ces signes.
C'est donc une maladie très commune.
En fait, le second avantage d'être médecin,
c'est de pouvoir faire des expériences sur vos propres maladies.
Donc, il y a 10 ans, nous avons commencé,
nous avons amené ce procédé en laboratoire,
et nous avons lancé des expériences simples,
essayant de traiter mécaniquement la maladie.
Nous avons essayer d'injecter des produits chimiques dans les genoux d'animaux
pour essayer d'inverser la dégénérescence cartilagineuse,
et essayer de mettre un terme un rapide à un très long et douloureux procédé,
essentiellement ça n'a rien donné.
Rien n'est arrivé.
Et puis, il y a sept ans, nous avions reçu un étudiant chercheur d'Australie.
Les Australiens sont sympas,
car ils sont habitués à regarder le monde à l'envers.
(Rires)
Dan m'a suggéré : « Tu sais peut-être que c'est pas un problème mécanique,
peut-être pas chimique, mais peut-être un problème de cellule souche. »
En d'autres termes, deux hypothèses.
Numéro 1, il existe un type de cellule souche osseuse --
une cellule souche osseuse qui construit l’entièreté du squelette,
os, cartilages et les éléments fibreux du squelette,
comme les cellules souches dans le sang,
comme les cellules souches dans le système nerveux.
N°2, peut-être que la dégénérescence ou le dysfonctionnement d'une cellule souche
est ce qui cause arthrite ostéochondrale, une maladie très commune.
Donc en fait la question c'était : cherchions-nous une pilule
quand nous aurions en réalité dû chercher une cellule ?
Donc nous avons changé nos modèles,
et nous avons commencé à chercher une cellule souche squelettique.
Et pour résumer une fois encore,
il y a 5 ans, nous avons trouvé ces cellules.
Elles vivent à l'intérieur du squelette.
Voilà un schéma, et puis une vraie photo de l'une d'elles.
Le truc blanc, c'est l'os,
et ces colonnes rouges que vous voyez et les cellules jaunes
sont des cellules qui proviennent d'une cellule souche squelettique,
des colonnes de cartilage,des colonnes d'os venant d'une seule cellule.
Ces cellules sont fascinantes. Elles ont 4 propriétés.
N°1 elles vivent où l'on s'attend à ce qu'elles vivent.
Elles vivent juste en dessous de la surface de l'os
en dessous du cartilage.
Vous savez, en biologie, c'est localiser, localiser.
Et elles ont bougé dans l'endroit
approprié et ont formé du cartilage et des os.
Ça en est une [propriété].
Voilà une propriété intéressante.
Vous pouvez les enlever du squelette,
vous pouvez les cultiver dans des boites de Pétri en labo,
et elles se tuent à former du cartilage.
Vous vous souvenez qu'on ne pouvait pas en former ?
Ces cellules veulent former du cartilage.
Elles s'enroulent dans leur cartilage.
Elles sont aussi, numéro 3,
les réparatrices de fractures les plus efficaces que nous ayons jamais trouvées.
Ceci est un petit os, un os de souris que nous avons fracturé et
laissé se soigner par lui-même.
Ces cellules souches sont arrivées, et ont réparé,en jaune, l'os
en blanc, le cartilage, quasiment complètement.
Assez pour que si vous les labellisez avec de la teinture fluorescente,
vous pouvez les voir comme une sorte de colle pour cellule,
arrivant dans l'endroit de la fracture,
la réparer localement et puis arrêter leur travail.
Voilà, la quatrième est la plus menaçante,
et c'est que leur nombre décline vertigineusement,
vertigineusement, se divise par dix, par cinquante, en fonction de votre âge.
Et voilà ce qui arrive, vraiment,
c'est que l'on se trouve dans un changement perceptuel.
Nous avions commencé par chercher des pilules
mais nous avions trouvé des théories.
Et d'une certaine façon,
nous nous étions accrochés à cette idée :
cellule, organisme, environnements,
parce que nous pensions maintenant aux cellules souches osseuses,
nous pensions à l'arthrite en termes de maladie cellulaire.
La question est devenue : y a t-il des organes ?
Pouvons-nous les développer en organe externe ?
Pouvons-nous implanter du cartilage à l'endroit du traumatisme ?
Et peut-être la plus intéressante :
peut-on faire l'ascension & créer l'environnement ?
Vous savez, on sait que l'exercice remodèle les os
mais bon, personne ici ne va faire de l'exercice.
Donc, pouvez-vous imaginer une façon de passivement charger et décharger l'os
pour pouvoir recréer ou régénérer un cartilage dégénérescent ?
Et peut-être plus intéressant et plus important,
peut-on l'appliquer mondialement en dehors de la médecine ?
Ce qui est en jeu, comme je l'ai déjà dit, ce n'est pas tuer quelque chose,
mais cultiver quelque chose.
Et ça soulève une série de, je pense, questions encore plus intéressantes
sur la façon dont on envisage le futur de la médecine.
Le traitement pourrait-il être une cellule et non une pilule ?
Comment ferions-nous grandir ces cellules ?
Et pour stopper la croissance maligne de ces cellules ?
Nous avons connaissance des problèmes de potentiel de croissance.
Peut-on implanter des gènes suicidaires dans ces cellules
pour stopper leur croissance ?
Votre médicament pourrait-il être un organe créé à l’extérieur de votre corps
et puis implanté dans votre corps ?
Pourrait-ce stopper une partie de la dégénérescence ?
Et si les organes avaient besoin d'avoir une mémoire ?
Dans les cas de maladies du système nerveux, certains organes ont une mémoire.
Peut-on réimplanter cette mémoire ?
Pourrions-nous stocker ces organes ?
Chaque organe devra-t-il être développé d'un être humain propre
et réimplanté ?
Et peut-être le plus déroutant,
votre médicament pourrait-il être un environnement ?
Peut-on breveter un environnement ?
Vous savez, dans toutes les cultures,
les shamans ont utilisé l'environnement comme traitement.
Pourrions-nous imaginer ça dans notre futur ?
J'ai beaucoup parlé de modèles. J'ai débuté ce colloque avec des modèles
Permettez-moi de terminer sur la construction de modèles.
C'est ce qu'on fait en tant que scientifiques.
Vous savez, quand un architecte construit un modèle,
il ou elle essaye de montrer un monde miniature.
Mais quand un scientifique construit un modèle,
il ou elle essaye de montrer le monde métaphoriquement.
Il ou elle essaye de créer une nouvelle façon de voir.
Le premier est un changement d'échelle. Le deuxième est un changement de perception.
Les antibiotiques ont créé un tel changement de perception
dans notre façon de penser à la médecine, qui est colorée, distordue,
très réussie, la façon dont nous avons pensé la médecine depuis cent ans.
Mais nous avons besoin de nouveau modèles pour penser la médecine dans le futur.
Voilà ce qui est en jeu.
Vous savez, il y a une tendance populaire qui clame
que la raison pour laquelle nous n'avons pas eu l'impact transformant
sur le traitement des maladies
est parce que nous n'avons pas de médicaments assez puissants,
et c'est partiellement vrai.
Mais peut-être que la raison est
que nous n'avons pas de façon assez puissante de penser la médecine.
C'est certainement vrai que
ce serait génial d'avoir de nouveaux traitements.
Mais peut-être que ce qui est vraiment en jeu a trois fins intangibles :
mécanismes, modèles, métaphores.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson: J'aime beaucoup cette métaphore.
Comment est-ce que ça se relie ?
A technologieville on parle beaucoup
de la personnalisation de la médecine,
que nous avons toutes ces données et ces traitements médicaux du futur
qui seront pour vous spécifiquement, votre génome, votre contexte actuel.
Est-ce que cela s'applique au modèle que vous avez ici ?
S.Mukherjee : C'est une question très intéressante.
On a pensé à la personnalisation de la médecine
beaucoup en termes génomiques.
C'est parce que le gène est une métaphore si dominante,
pour utiliser les mêmes termes, dans la médecine actuelle,
nous pensons que le génome mènera à la personnalisation de la médecine.
Mais bien sûr, le génome est juste la base
d'une longue chaîne d'êtres.
La première unité de cette chaîne est, en fait, la cellule.
Donc, si nous délivrons vraiment la médecine de cette façon
nous devons penser à personnaliser les thérapies cellulaires
et puis personnaliser les organes et les thérapies organiques,
pour finalement personnaliser la thérapie d'immersion dans l'environnement.
Donc je pense qu'à chaque étape, vous savez,
il y a cette métaphore : il y des tortues tout le long.
Bah, là, c'est la personnalisation qui est tout du long.
CA : Quand vous dites que le traitement pourrait être
une cellule et non une pilule,
vous parlez du potentiel de vos propres cellules.
SM : Absolument. CA : Converties aux cellules souches,
et peut-être testées contre certains médicaments ou autre chose, et préparées.
SM : Il n'y a pas de peut-être. C'est ce que l'on fait.
C'est ce qui se passe, et en fait, on avance doucement,
sans s'éloigner des génomes, mais en les incorporant
dans des systèmes multi-ordres, semi-autonomes, auto-régulateurs,
comme les cellules, les organes, les environnements.
CA : Merci énormément.
SM : C'est moi. Merci.